cash kid you can catch me on the bootleg
head podcast let's get it
through like hell podcast special guest
in here shout out to cash kid man
Detroit's in the building yes sir all
right cash kid uh you came in here and
you were like yo well I don't know if no
your boy pointed out I don't have a
LeBron poster but I do have a LeBron toy
here LeBron should go
LeBron to go into go to basketball the
greatest of all time I agree of all the
time when it comes to when it kind of uh
overall when it comes to basketball
basketball he make everybody we can make
people better than you feel me make he
could just you feel me just but I feel
like he just get so much hate just gonna
see LeBron well you're the best you're
gonna get hate like I'm surprised being
from Detroit like LeBron because the
Cavaliers kind of like it's a little
rival there you know they kind of you
know they ended the the Ben Wallace ears
you know man I don't care about none of
that what was that number seven LeBron
is done I'm going for LeBron over the
business okay
so Lakers versus pistons in the finals
2023 by the way mathematically not
possible Kate Cunningham has been
injured all year in a hypothetical
situation that happens you're going for
the Lakers
uh
I'ma say
honestly I probably
I'm gonna go for the Lakers in my heart
but just being but on Instagram you guys
I'm gonna probably have to go for the
city just because yeah it's the city but
but in my heart I'm gonna be like deep
down I know how much I like LeBron so
you hear me but yeah like I still I
never count the Lakers out one of the
worst trades of the year was when the
Pistons traded Sadiq Bay
[Music]
yeah we'll see man uh well listen you're
from the East side of Detroit
um how obviously you know there seems to
be like kind of a contrast in terms of
like the East Side versus the west side
of Detroit stylistically I've always had
people say like the west side is more on
some like players and the east side is
more of some like
you know grimy is that a fair assessment
I mean like a different city like the
west side like it was I ain't gonna say
they was like players it was like just
more fresh like they just looking for a
day but but
like me we probably even we was like we
was I was a baby kid I'm happy to wear
the same three four days in a row right
all right I was but I said I probably
looked at dirty as hell that might make
you look great because you look dirty as
hell when you dirty you look gravy right
right yeah see I I do feel like uh
another thing that's been dope recently
is it feels like a lot more uh artists
from each side are like working together
man that's all they really take for it
feels like there's a lot of unity in
Detroit to turn the city up that's what
we needed for real for real do you feel
like that that was what was kind of
holding Detroit back before uh sometimes
man to be honest it's just timing
everything just give me everything
everything had to fall into place for
real for real the devil's been getting
kicked down but
which is really like it's really I think
it really was up to us as artists to
really put that work in to know like
look man you feel me still in our flows
they're still in our beats they're
trying to be like because we might as
well you hear me all we got to do is
really go do this you hear me go harder
yeah do you feel like uh because I do
feel like Detroit has had like a
obviously I'm not aside from like you
know the Big Sean's and the M Ms but
just kind of the sound that we kind of
associate with Detroit has been like a
sound that other regions have gotten
some credit for that y'all have been
doing do you feel like
the the the sound was bit a bit and you
guys are finally because everyone's
signing people from Detroit now I feel
like Detroit's like the hottest city in
hip-hop man Detroit got real talent like
and anything done just the beginning
it's really got real talent like because
then people ain't even heard yet like
been knowing like been knowing like if
everybody is there ain't nobody gonna
really put on unless unless we put on
for ourselves
ain't gonna really like yeah Detroit got
the one of the best rappers out there
but right you can't really prove unless
you remember unless we but we are we
here now do you feel like uh things
could have been different had like
Eminem maybe being the biggest rap
artist ever embraced more of the Detroit
scene because it feels like he never
really
embraced
the new move movement out of Detroit I
mean even the last like 10 even like
when Doughboy cash out was like CTE it
just kind of felt like there was like
Eminem was just over here on an island
and then there's this like Street that's
like bubbling in the scene and I really
never felt like he has embraced probably
didn't like he probably really wasn't he
remembered a different type of artists I
feel like when you that type of man
that's Eminem I feel like he probably
don't even listen like he probably
wasn't listening right like to that type
of she probably would just focus on him
he probably had his own people somebody
was an artist yeah because I'm the type
of I'm like that I don't really like it
right like sometimes you don't even
listen to like you hear me you're just
getting them zones where it's been times
where I didn't listen to nobody but my
people I listen to everybody now and
plus I feel like Royce has done a good
job of like embracing some of the young
yeah he could be yeah hell yeah so he
probably liked the boy's foot Eminem
Eminem can't relieve him but I feel like
Eminem I mean Eminem he I got a song I'm
on the future with Eminem son like I
can't I ain't got no bad nothing it is
you hear me so how many artists were on
that rack
[Music]
yeah it's funny because I forget who I
was talking to but they were like man I
didn't know I was gonna how are you
gonna say but it's like I think a couple
of people on that song didn't know they
were going to be on a song with the
other person man how crazy was that like
did you like were you nervous getting on
Detroit too and like doing that record
like did you kind of understand the
concept of it like I didn't know what it
was gonna do I was really hell no I
wasn't nervous I was just we read a lot
of songs in that we did a lot of songs
we man we was working for days because I
wasn't there with us like we was in
there working but what was that like
like explain what you mean was it like a
studio session with Sean yep all of us
was there like everybody a lot of
Detroit rappers was there even because
they didn't make the song everybody was
there and then we did more music but
they just and then somebody wouldn't
even hear me like they just they just
you feel me they just laughing like they
just was picking different beats and
putting different versions that one they
was putting that [__] together night
they put it together nice though
when your mom finds out you're on a song
with Eminem is she excited hell yeah she
like yo what the [__] son my mama my
mama one of them people that she I feel
like she only been I'm just her son her
she don't even know like she late to
realizing who our son but everybody
knows Eminem yeah yeah it's like it's
like this is Eight Mile really yeah yeah
my mama yeah yeah everybody calling me
everybody hitting me you're like what
the [__] yeah yeah I love Big Sean man
Sean's one of the most genuine guys in
the game man yeah for sure you guys got
unreleased [__] together we got a uh no
we ain't got no relationship we need to
get in that [__] though yeah we did a
couple [__] there but I don't really
remember a lot of them songs yeah like
yeah for sure do you uh you've been
embraced by the West Coast in a
heavyweight La yeah you know you got
[__] with you I think blue but is blue
books on your album yeah yeah yeah you
obviously got you worked with oh Jeezy
um I know blueface [__] with you
what is it about I because I do feel
like there is like a connection between
specifically the bay the bay in Detroit
really got like a [__] thing going on
they're like it's like a bromance going
on you know what I'm saying but like how
did you end up like really kind of
locking in with LA and having La embrace
you the way they have [__] forever I'm
just like I'm a [__] that just like
when I say talent I just I don't know if
a [__] ain't gonna have no like [__]
ain't gonna be nobody ain't gotta know
if I like the music I'm banging actually
I'm writing you I'm tapping in I'm doing
this home with you my song you hear me
and I'm putting that [__] on my I just
wanna if I see China [__] bro I'm [__]
with this music let's just put this [__]
for yeah feel me that's what this [__]
have fun and help [__] and
other cities I didn't even notice that
[__] looked at me like they're
here and chill out y'all really [__]
not here they they [__] with you hard
out there they thought I was from here
[__] told me like yeah we we
thought you we was wondering like why we
never seen you like we ain't never seen
you in school or nothing we thought you
was from her you act just like us yeah I
never noticed that but hey I guess I
[__] with I [__] with like the Kelly
said hard they got the hardest rapper
right who was the first uh like couple
artists you really like locked in with
out here in a bay or L.A well either
give me like a couple for me first
[__] was yada uh SOB
um a little yes
uh let me think man you know his brother
Ralphie I thought I [__] with blue blood
yeah man there's so many [__] in L.A
bro I don't even know where like I
thought I [__] with the hell saying like
literally like yeah Draco obviously was
somebody else who I feel like uh has
like a lot of influence over a lot of
people that he doesn't get credit for
the rest of the piece to Draco what did
y'all how long ago did you link up with
him before you got locked up with him
you never met him no no I met him like
we used to always pay time and talk like
from years but I never seen them in
person like never super tapped it with
Detroit yeah
so he's gonna be on your new album
that's big man yeah yeah how so that how
old is that record
[__] that [__] was like man how long ago
he passed like what was that two years
ago that [__] Tommy passed December
remember two years it's been about a
year but like three years ago like the
tape like that [__] like three years ago
then yeah he was in the studio I
remember like because he did a couple
freestyles on my show and one day he
just was just playing hella shitty out
with Detroit he was playing all kinds of
[__] with him and Peezy and like he was
super super like dialed into what y'all
were doing out there it was a workaholic
then they used to be working that [__]
yeah yeah
that [__] crazy I do feel like you are
uh when it comes to like
I I'm very excited to hear the Blue Book
song because I do feel like you guys
might have some amazing Sports
references in your records oh yeah oh
yeah hey we got a man we generally got
two tapes together I feel like I feel
like we're so much together yeah blue
books you and baby Tron have just like
the most random Sports one-liners
that like you really gotta be like a
sports nerd to understand like sometimes
like you you know just referring to like
certain players on a bench or you know
how have you always been like a hardcore
Sports guy uh I'm a well not hardcore
Sports I'm just like football on the
back football back I mean those are the
two sports no one watches baseball who's
on the [__] who's on the [__]
Tigers who knows
I don't even know who's on the Tigers I
don't know bro I don't watch that [__]
at all they had like Miguel Cabrera like
10 years ago I'll watch I'll watch
hockey before I watch baseball oh no
they had that [__] picture uh
Verlander Verlander right Justin
Verlander these people I ain't gonna lie
Diamond dimebags
how you know this don't say y'all I'm
from Arizona
[Music]
don't say y'all are from the bay
that [__] six hours away
don't give me credit for that
yeah no no one watches baseball yeah
it's a you know what I like about
Detroit is unlike every other [__]
major city all y'all's Arenas are in the
same area it didn't used to be what was
the firework in Pistons it was far as
hell
and you guys got a Little Caesars Arena
yeah the Pistons just to be like an hour
away in [__] somewhere else
when you go to listen when you go to the
Little Caesars Arena yeah the Palace of
Auburn Hills yeah yeah as far as hell
dude they got five dollar hot and readys
at the arena
yeah everybody's taxing not that [__]
they got a good day cut do you not
disappointing that bee to [__] go to
the Little Caesars Arena and they're
still taxing you I didn't offer that
[__] like I this should be six dollars
at tops especially if you get the extra
most fastest with the extra cheese and
the extra pepperoni oh yeah yeah 7 36.
man I have to work at Los Angeles so I
went to like six different conies out
there
I'm not gonna lie one or two of them are
solid
I went to one by
what's the name of that strip club truth
trust truth so you went to um Nikki D's
that [__] was terrible do you know what
this horrible uh I went to Papa's which
was Sada baby spot
and then you know where else I ate that
was just just atrocious food what'd you
get from Kong
I don't even I didn't get I didn't get a
hot dog I'll tell you that I got I got
[__] Wings somewhere I don't know bro
I got a [__] omelet another place
I got a piece of cheesecake yeah uh
just a very vast menu you could get
anything at these places what is the
Coney to go to if someone goes to
Detroit
but that's on Six Mile and um Gunston
what would you suggest someone order
I can't tell people my order what's your
order I'd be high as hell I get
different [__] every time like today
I'll be want this the next day I'll be
like okay if I'm a [__] tourist and
I'm going to Zorba's
what are you telling me to get
what's like then what what are you off
of we like I'm off of weed I'm I eat
edible oh I just took a Blue Rhino I
just got done
you know we're [__] turnt up we just
left [__] we just we just we just
left truth you know what I mean okay I
decided not to eat it truth because I
wanted to go to Oconee they damn I gotta
get the chili cheese some chili cheese
for a show for sure yeah you hide you
[__] around me I feel like you're like a
milkshake or something milkshake and
chili cheese fries yeah I don't give a
[__] I'm high as hell all that [__] girl
we gotta you gotta get that [__] bro
you hear him you ever have m m spaghetti
no hell no oh I see you were trying
there it was not good yeah she was
terrible like that
what type of chefs and [__] was it like
was it like I don't know bro that [__]
was like um if you like
lived it like a white lady's house and
she made spaghetti and two days later
you heated it up oh my God
it was like that yeah [__] it was that
horrible it wasn't good what was on the
menu at all like just spaghetti you
could get spaghetti number one two three
it's spaghetti or spaghetti sandwich
that sandwich probably would have hit
though no I tried both
the best [__] on the menu was the bread
what what's odd coming that spaghetti
bread
it's a very normal like it's just
there's like two things you can get it's
like in and out burger you have In and
Out Burger yeah oh yeah [__] yeah they
don't got it out there do they no no no
no I ain't gonna lie Detroit's food was
little it was all right I don't know if
I went to the right spots or not
gotta just have a good mom or Auntie or
something that ought to cook very well
there was like a fake um Raising Canes
that we had there that was Detroit yeah
it was so weird what's it going what was
it called cousin Joe's or Uncle Joe's or
something Joe's I don't know that [__]
was fired yeah the sauce and everything
everything oh my God it was so good I
love raising cans they have a fake
Raising Canes here actually would even
venture to say that it's a little better
because you can get the the breaded uh
shrimp instead of the chicken you know
Raising Canes you only get the chicken
and they give you the toast at this
place I gotta see this location
listen do you want to win some money
gotta stop the interview but listen
there's so many opportunities to gamble
to bet on your favorite sports to make
Sports more interesting NFL season is
over but it's all good because the
opportunities to win are just getting
started yeah look there's so many things
you can do we're talking about NCAA NBA
NHL UFC boxing there's Blackjack
tournaments so much money to get in on
on and check this out y'all if you sign
up right now using the promo code
bootleg do it right now you can get a
welcome bonus up to a thousand dollars
plus you're gonna get a free 150
000 March Madness bracket contest entry
that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you're gonna put in 200 bucks to
give you 200 you put a thousand they'll
give you another thousand right look
right now go to mybookie.ag sign up use
that promo code March Madness is upon us
so much great Sports just NBA season
playoffs are on the way man you could
like literally put together some crazy
props like uh I don't know over under on
a player that you like scoring you could
do a future on the MVP you think jokic
is going to win it you think Joel embiid
is going to win it Whatever It Is get in
on the action right now mybookie.ag with
that promo code bootleg when you sign up
get that free deposit bonus all right
bet anything anytime anywhere with my
bookie also shout out to our family at
hardean hardeen Las Vegas Yes you see
him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas
um so who also saw on this album that
you got coming
[__] I got a
man I got so many people in that [__] I
got about man five six seven features I
can't even think of who on on that [__]
right now I got I got 40 40 on that
[__] wait you got E40 840 No Cap
probably say I think I have the list
here yeah a good friend Ari oh yeah E40
and no cap I got some [__] on that [__]
I'm trying to think who all who else on
that [__] that
Jesus how many uh first of all how do
you link with E40 because he don't he
just ain't doing nothing like something
for everybody [__] he just uh I tapped
in with him like what's up huh oh I need
to do on some did he charge you I don't
know wow that was a problem I was I was
willing to pay yeah I mean that's
legendary for me I was living in the
paper like hell no what's up with it he
hit me like three days later like oh I
just saying this what's up with it send
it he gassed it went crazy wow talked
slippery as hell on that [__] you know
that's 40 you know he like so you send
it to him do you already kind of like no
like I'm I I cut this record I need 40
on this one yeah I made it like once I
did hurt beat I already knew like yeah
all right suggested like bro this [__]
if I hear him like 40 like this [__] I
think I sent him a couple song which one
thing here it's all crazy yeah I think
he probably picked that one for me all
right uh also a dope like scene is uh
what's going on in Flint obviously free
Rio uh RMC mics out there um
how would you kind of compare the two
cities flint and Detroit in terms of
like the music and just just like the
vibe of each Place [__] I already never
like hang up on that forever I went to
plan a couple times you know but Flint
that music scene is like them [__]
talk so crazy like they just oh they
just oh [__] talking that [__] real
different bro like
that's one of the that's one of the the
best rappers that came from Michigan
like that [__] so hard to me they sing
hard as hell like
that [__] the face of that [__] real
the face of Flint like that [__] I just
brought that [__] I could listen to
that [__] all day like that nigga's so
hard bro okay
Mike's fire and then I know uh BB the
Pac-Man's from there originally yep and
he's [__] player man that [__] funny
you guys don't have no music together uh
no we we always talk about it like I
ain't gonna lie every time I talk to him
we just be chopping up talking our [__]
yeah we need to get it in but we just
always just get just talking [__] like
just talking to be a hilarious song I
mean even a better music video we're
gonna put it I'm gonna put it together
y'all should do a podcast together or
something just shut the [__] just set it
up it'd be hilarious set it up yeah I
think he's in Texas but shout out to to
be a be the pack man he's he's a great
guy man and I [__] with Louie Ray from
Flint too he hard as hell he heard as
[__] uh right now obviously the city's
on fire you got guys like yourself
baby money uh Vezzo
Babyface Ray peasy I mean this
it's pretty crazy man like
um why do you think like finally
commercially the whole everybody's
finally kind of like popping off all at
the same time like you know what I'm
saying that because usually it only
takes one and I kind of want to give
some credit to T Grizzly because I do
kind of feel like T Grizzly kicked the
door down yeah for the for our type of
genre like yeah for like hip hop like
like just the street [__] yeah yeah yeah
everybody work together you feel me busy
being like popping and like if you hear
me anyways so once uh if you hear me
what's peasy it was pop once T Grizzly
popped off and [__] already I know that
they had songs together every time they
have fire I know they was about to come
with some fire and [__] so I know them
dogs gonna be broke down once everybody
got on it's like [__] just
pulling each other up that's how it's
supposed to be though Palatine uh man
the [__] still on it though the nigga's
still reaching back bringing everybody
anybody on the [__] everybody really
working for for real who's your personal
favorite right now beside yourself out
of uh at just the whole state of
Michigan Michigan [__] I'm gonna say
these I [__] with or
[__] with bees hard as hell I [__] with
uh see all the Detroit rappers I [__]
with it I [__] with V's hard as hell I
[__] with um
what's I [__] with heart as hell
[__] uh
let me think
teammates house no that was my favorite
Detroit rapper before he passed RP to
him photo of him hard as hell but right
now he's probably my favorite that's
what's up hard as hell who else is from
like kind of your immediate neighborhood
[__] uh pz Ray uh bezo what's in the
water over there the water I am from
Flint I mean like what's in the water in
your neighborhood that's a lot of
[__] hitters coming out of the world
you know what's crazy you thought I was
making a flint joke but I wouldn't do
such thing you try to put that on me I'm
not I thought I'm like are you don't put
the [__] Flint water joke on me
that's a little hanging fruit buddy I'm
not making that joke
[Laughter]
if you're gonna have water anyway
probably shouldn't have it in Flint you
gotta get the [__] water you gotta
get water bottles oh man
yeah you're the one who made the joke
for me
Jesus
anyway man
um so for you like obviously getting
ready to put an album out
um do you kind of feel like uh you know
Empire has kind of done so much for
Detroit I feel like in terms of kind of
like you know if we think about a lot of
the names we just mentioned they're with
Empire how important is it like
being with a label in a situation like
Empire that fully like embraced Detroit
prior to it being cool to do so I just
took a chance on a lot of people bro he
was going through the Bangladesh uh so
much [__] so much bad [__] had
so much bad [__] about Empires your
mother because they want to but really
Empire man they they they they they
really man they they even they they they
gonna help put that [__] put
what you need or behind you and they let
you be up they let you do what you want
to do like they let you be you if you
may not making you do nothing you don't
want to do they're not [__]
stopping you from doing nothing you want
to do either like they they like they
one of the best labels that I ever sat
down and you feel me talk to or ever
dealt with right I [__] with God as hell
are the teeth permanent or they they pop
out they pop out yeah yeah I am from
Florida yeah Florida boys is crazy
you know I lived in Florida I got a nice
teeth though I lived in Florida and uh
you know the guys with the real gold
shits usually for the most part don't
don't do the best in uh upkeeping them
say them but just be filthy
[__] breath just be crazy oh my
God the worst oh my God it's like it's
like you gotta understand if you're
gonna commit to like getting your teeth
like permanently inserted into some
different type of technical there's some
serious maintenance
did it take you a while to get used to
talking with those
um
yep yeah maybe like a month yeah yeah I
don't fell asleep with them [__] and
I did everything but eat with them so
I'm used to them but you're not I'll be
forgetting out of David in my mouth
Detroit's definitely like a hustler City
uh you know the first place I ever saw
uh the empty bootleg weed bags at the
liquor store
yeah so then maybe like I'm like yo I
can never buy weed in Detroit because I
don't know what the [__]
man you [__] around about some fire
first if you come and somewhere else
actually some [__] at the store in
Detroit but where I'll find some fire
for obviously like like one of the OG
scamming cities in the country like do
you feel like growing up in Detroit like
kind of instills a certain hustle or
like attitude and like you know how you
kind of live your day-to-day life hell
yeah yeah you always get like certain
instincts [__] be lost as hell
like a Detroit you gotta keep your head
on the swivel all the time so like oh
you come to places like L.A you should
[__] already know like you hear
me like yeah this mother you hear me it
get Wicked here so you gotta
[__] that just and showing where
they could just be loose as hell and
just do [__] you ain't gonna had a
[__] mindset or the
[__] experience to know how to
move you know life especially especially
when you once you've known and popular
and with jury and all that you got to
move way different then
from Detroit I should teach you that
[__] before you even get Fame like you
could be a [__] regular person
and you just you feel me you you
cautious already know how to move
already yeah yo talk to me about Detroit
white trash because it's a serious thing
huh Detroit white trash what you mean by
that it's just different Detroit white
trash yeah like uh the type of people
that go to a Tech N9ne concert on a
Wednesday night in Detroit
about white people in Detroit yeah
yes because I was in Detroit and I went
to a Tech Nine concert what was the uh
what was the atmosphere like
it was uh
did the whole like oh
it's a concert full of people who would
be Eminem had he had not made it
[Laughter]
it was just some like
[__] man I was like oh this is this is
different white trash this is like Ford
factory white trash
I got some cool white friends and I'm
from I'm from Arizona so I know a thing
or two about white trash we're like the
meth Capital you know I was just looking
around and I was just like
I was just surrounded by like
a type of white trash I'd never been
surrounded by a trailer like it was like
certain yeah maybe trailer but it just
like Blue Collar trailer you know
like their grandpa probably died like
assembling a Ford like
F-150 you know just a Detroit D on the
neck are you saying oh okay you know
I know what type are you talking about
that yeah I got some cool little white
white friends and like I I I don't I
don't know that you might have seen some
different type of [__] I don't even know
nobody that will go today
it was a fun time
then I went uh I went to uh the trailer
park That Eminem grew up in yeah just
because why not just you there I'm in
Detroit I ate the [__] spaghetti
I might as well go see the trailer park
right yeah it's [__] up over there bro
and probably you've been over there but
yeah it probably look better than it did
though like well I guess it got level
but driving through that trailer park is
[__] up in there I don't think I never
draw with the rapper I probably uh
visited it like just to see like oh this
one about everybody but I ain't really
it's Detroit I really didn't care too
much to go so as a kid do you ever like
go back and or like look listen Detroit
has like a a historical history in in
our culture and Hip-Hop uh I I think of
like J dilla you know what I'm saying
who's one of the greatest producers of
all time does that kind of [__] even hit
your radar like the slum Villages of the
world the Dilla the you know the black
milks that like real underground boom
bat Detroit [__] no I don't know I never
believe I heard of that to be honest J
dilla I don't know what it is you've
never heard of Jay Dilla no who it is
he's one of the greatest producers ever
damn ever
so Jay Dilla is like uh so
I mean man there's so many Classics yeah
I mean I only got my water do we got any
extra water I think we're out that's
good no you're good I mean you want to
Waterfall this you can't yeah all right
my space man let me go straight [__] uh
damn Jay Dillon I got I'm gonna send you
some links you just gotta tap in bro
yeah J dilla JD uh he was also a part of
have you heard of Slum Village yeah I
heard her name but I don't like know
nothing that come along with I don't
know information about Sun Village and
then there was a black milk is dope
obviously you heard Royce the five nine
of course what's wrong with him hell
yeah uh yeah Roy that was kind of like
the same kind of era of like you know
there was yeah yeah damn bro Jay Dillard
bro yeah I feel good I feel bad and I'm
sleeping I feel bad too man damn [__] I
gotta put you on man please hey we got
to stop the interview to tell you about
our good Folks at Blue chew baby that's
right A lot of people keep asking me
does Bluetooth work [__] yeah it does
and if you don't believe me they'll give
you a whole month for free right now if
you go to bluetooth.com and use that
promo code bootleg that's bootry.com
promo code bootleg you get a month of
blue chew for free delivered to your
[__] house all you do is pay five
dollars in shipping what is blue tree
you ask well let me tell you it has the
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable tablet but it is
discreetly delivered right to your
doorstep no awkward doctor's visits
imagine going and telling uh an old guy
about your dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you can do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
gonna send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know
that you came and it came all right so
what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just drop their new mint chewable which
is the same exact active ingredient as
Levitra so many options for you at
Bluetooth to make sure your dick is
right going into the springtime baby
look spring break's coming uh are you
gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner going to be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month's supply for
free and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
WrestleMania is coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the park at Odd Socks look the
most comfortable socks in the world they
got The Odd Socks Basics that you need
on your feet uh all you got to do is go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg at checkout
you'll save 20 off your total order
underwear socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola draws Coca-Cola socks so much
always going on in Odd Socks I'm gonna
always say my favorites are the WWE in
the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you will
save 20 off at checkout shout out to
them most comfortable socks in the world
crazy comfortable underwear my goodness
if you ain't got Odd Socks on your feet
and ass what are you doing out in these
streets all right go to
hotsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview who's on your Detroit Mount
Rushmore of hip-hop all time all the
time ever obviously J Dill is not on
there is that something right before
yeah
all the time
Eminem
anyway damn that's hard
[__]
I'm about to say Dej Loaf by the way Dej
Loaf is a goat
everybody's joking her [__] right yeah
yeah
[__] she didn't love though so it kind
of might be a little better today
I'm gonna say Eminem Dej Loaf
that's hard for people I had to put
[__] I'm gonna have to put tea Grizzly
on there okay
[__]
I wanna um
that's her
all right well I gotta put that female
in there I gotta put cash down on there
she's expecting the baby your shoes have
a baby or something I don't even know
she's beautiful I think she had a baby I
think she's had a baby yeah she's too
hard to do that that's my fault right
there yo is there like
I would say like 2010 to 09 2011 era
there was like this like narrative that
like Detroit was like a no-fly zone
and like uh you know there was like the
rumors that like Rick Ross couldn't
perform because trick trick had Banner
from the city yeah I don't even want to
get into all that but like was there
ever like a point in time where like
Detroit was like an area where like you
really had to like super check in or
where is it like that currently oh [__]
yeah I'll stay there so I don't know
[__] maybe maybe other people gotta
checking in [__] but right they better
[__] I guess [__] but
I don't know man I ain't never checked
it in nowhere like it's a free word I
would go wherever the [__] I want to go
but hell no I mean that should probably
just like if that [__] said tell the
attorney he can't come they must gonna
be on dog yes when you get to that [__]
but they ain't gonna do with me I don't
know but I don't give a [__] who come to
Detroit if a [__] would have cut in
that [__] would come out like I ain't
gonna never try to tell them [__] you
can't cut my Sandy right because I'm
about to be
if you could do a collab tape with uh
another artist from Detroit or from the
Detroit area who would it be
probably my boy Swan Jason oh yeah but
we like we like if he'll meet us like
we'll just know each other even right I
feel like even baby Tron would have
hilarious oh my whole funny asses [__]
we gotta do a little
epic
yeah
you got to do a freestyle over Jay Dilla
beat now this is crazy
damn I'm sleeping yeah [__] [__] it's
all good bro uh uh what's the name of
the album baby kid three baby kid three
up
the original baby Kids the movie did you
watch it as a kid uh I watched it a
little bit I watched a little a lot of
bit you hear me but a little louder yeah
it resonated with you enough to yeah
because it's like reminding me of myself
like it was just badass kids man I'm
just one of them kids that just ain't
give a [__] about [__] like you hear me
what was something that like for you do
you remember like a moment where like
you kind of
you started to focus on your career and
stop like maybe [__] around with
other [__] like and you really kind of
dug in on the rap [__] and decided to
take it serious was there something
happened or um to be honest yeah I just
literally just be having fun with this
[__] just having fun taking a one step
at a time if you remember my mom always
work hard at the [__] so just like my
life like even before I was like female
I just hit the studio like like down
there I hit the studio a lot like like a
job like you hear me that [__] like
every day type [__] so [__] it's just
always gonna I treat it like like if you
hear me I don't even hear me I'm gonna
always go hard it's like it's not like a
it's not like a it's not like a job but
I treat it like a job I'm just having
fun with the [__] you feel me so I don't
really you feel me I really don't care
if you hear me if you go too far or if
it don't go far I'm just having fun I
really do [__] for me and my people
really I'm just having fun with this
[__] long as I can make as long as I can
maintain money and take care of myself
and my family up this [__] I ain't
tripping to her if you're not even
tripping too hard I'm just having fun
and and and living in the moment man and
making memories somebody who's a sports
fan who also is obviously a very
successful artist there is a basketball
player who we all love to watch who I
feel
kind of wants to be a rapper right now
and his name is John Murray
John Moran is out here wowing I say
nobody out here he's outside outside
what's the over-under on when Sada baby
ends up signing him as well because you
know Sada baby signed miles Bridges
miles hard as hell he's actually dope no
miles Bridges makes some records for
sure that boy could probably be a rapper
for real I mean he does rap yeah but I
mean he might have to be I don't know if
anyone's giving him a deal he could be
successful yeah for real he that hurts
me heard I can see John Moran's next to
kind of break away and just you know
but he shouldn't let's be honest he
shouldn't he has his own [__] Nike
shoes yeah facts yeah yeah he just man
some people just you know you never know
what people going through you never know
some people can't live the streets alone
sometimes these Elms drive you crazy
even if they're not from the streets
effects the Suburban streets there it is
okay another Detroit artist I gotta ask
if they're on your radar
Insane Clown Posse who do you know about
the Insane Clown Posse may you making
that name up bro you don't know about
ICP you serious
wow Insane Clown Posse hey yo throw me
the remote
no no I'm gonna put it on [__]
YouTube
where's the remote so you know
jabby walking type [__] Jabberwockies
yes they're like one of the most
they're one of the most successful
Independent Artists ever
type [__] no they do they do really
shitty rap music
are they popular they had people ICP bro
they were popping in the 90s they were
like people with the other dudes or they
were popping with uh they were beefing
with Eminem
man what the [__] they was clown chasing
bro nah they were they were doing their
thing bruh I mean
wait so you've never seen uh uh a
hatchet man tattoo on a white trash
hey what is she real bro they have a
Gathering of the Juggalos they have like
a festival in the middle of the
[Music]
boat really
goes on it's terrible hold on let me let
me let's do it real quick and I see
Miracles every day
okay [__] this this is terrible let's
look at it should not be what you got to
do though is they have this thing called
the uh they have this thing called the
Gathering of the Juggalos there's a oh
wait this is actually this is ICP when
they were popping this is from the
this [__] ass as hell
this [__] is terrible right
do you want to know what's crazy about
ICP though check this out they were
designated their fan base is called
Juggalos
and so their fan base was designated a
official gang by the FBI so their fan
base is considered a gang
so they have like their fan base they
call themselves Juggalos yeah
and the FBI designated them an actual
gang
so they're fans but like and obviously
they're not a gang but like it was kind
of an unfair thing
but dude you get these Juggalo
[__]
God no God no
so they have like this Festival every
year called the Gathering of the
Juggalos
and it's just like white trash they hang
out
they don't they don't shower much
they do meth OD
they got on a [__] long ass tee
now that's Detroit where I trash I was
talking about right there so that's what
I saw at that Tech Nine concert be
honest
see look they got that email for
tomorrow
say it's a way of life criminologists
call it death authorities are classified
Juggalos as a gang in Utah
Pennsylvania and California they're from
Detroit
these [__] guys wow I don't think
nobody in Detroit none of these [__] I
ain't gonna lie no I'm telling you some
people know them
they're I mean dude they're big bro
don't [__] they're they're big I mean
they're and the thing is is they're not
big in the YouTube area they're big like
in the 90s and [__]
but like it's pretty it's pretty it's
pretty crazy you know what I think we
need to try to get you booked at the
Gathering of the Juggalos [__]
with them [__] bro I guarantee you you
get a bag over there
so [__] crazy bro I'm jugged them
drunk ass [__]
bro the crazy thing is is like big
Detroit artists have done the Gathering
of the Juggalos
so they have a drug Bridge there
so there's like a drug bridge where and
there's a [__] Hut where [__] just
getting trains around man it's crazy
see look at me educating you on Detroit
Hip Hop man appreciate it man by the way
history you do not need to go back and
listen to any of their music because it
is atrocious you need to dislike them
[__] right now no no they're cool
guys I'm sure like you know I respect I
respect their independent hustle they're
not bad dudes I'm just not a fan of the
music now
J Dillard we got to put you on yeah I
need
I need to get hit man ASAP and we got to
get you booked at the Gathering of the
Juggalos you know what they would do so
I never knew
that Insane Clown Posse okay so Faygo
right so I go to Detroit you guys got a
million flavors of Faygo yeah so I
didn't know up until recently that Faygo
wasn't ICP soda I always thought they
owned it because they they was like they
talked about it so much or they and at
their concerts they'll take like 102
liters and they have this like Faygo gun
and they shoot the two leaders into the
[__] crowd so it's a bunch of sticky
Faygo drenched white kids who don't
shower
it's interesting yeah you know we should
go to ICP concert together man I think
you already went been a one imagine was
lit
yeah it was ICP Tech Nine and uh Bone
Thugs-N-Harmony I was in high school oh
man it was like 5 000 people so they was
really like like that dude it's crazy
yeah anyway man well listen I appreciate
you pulling up I already know you
definitely uh got the new one album
coming in April right the album is
coming out March 31st oh end of March
yes sir March 31st tons of features
Drake goes on there baby face Ray got a
couple people yeah got a coat yeah oh
yeah yeah
and yeah yes sir appreciate you pulling
up bro hey by the way for having me you
had a crazy freestyle go watch that on
YouTube I gotta go see I don't even
remember